effectivement ce que le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell
évoqué tout à l'heure juste avant le
début du discours du discours de
vladimir poutine si la souveraineté du
territoire ukrainien est attaqué il y
aura des sanctions s'était quasiment
automatique dans ses propos il ya
évidemment différents degrés de
sanctions affirme-t-il une invasion
militaire ce n'est pas la même chose que
la reconnaissance de l'indépendance de
ces deux républiques de données est ce
qui est lougansk mais en revanche il y à
ces sanctions qui sont prêtes avec cette
gradation tout le danger pour les
observateurs ici de l'union européenne
c'est que cette reconnaissance
transforme ces deux républiques en
nouveaux conflits gelés à terme c'est à
dire qu'il ne se passe rien
militairement et qu'on se retrouve dans
la situation de l'abkhazie de l'ossétie
du sud où la transnistrie par exemple
l'autre aspect politique plus important
est que pour les européens cette
reconnaissance par vladimir poutine par
la russie de l'indépendance de ces deux
républiques constitue une atteinte à la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et ils ont
toujours dit que c'était ça le véritable
acte d'agression on le sait en 2014 ils
ont mis beaucoup de temps à réagir à
l'invasion de la crimée il a fallu
attendre marioupol quelques mois plus
tard pour que les européens se réveille
en quelque sorte la leurs instruments
sont prêts ils voulaient couper la
russie de l'économie européenne c'est
probablement ça la décision principale
qui peut être prise iront ils jusqu'au
bout rien ne laisse présager et quel
sera exactement l'étendue des sanctions
et ont évoqué un feu mais emmanuel
macron à 100 était en tout cas s'ils
étaient mis d'accord avec vladimir
poutine la nuit dernière aujourd'hui les
caduque c'est l'accord est caduc
effectivement on a essayé de maintenir
l'espoir au niveau européen on ne sait
que pendant très longtemps la position
française d'avoir un contact très haut
niveau avec la russie avait été vu avec
beaucoup de scepticisme par les baltes
par les polonais les suédois et les
néerlandais par exemple voulait que la
russie donne des gages avant qu'on
imagine un sommet entre l'union
européenne et le kremlin c'est pour
cette raison que cette proposition
franco allemande
avait été repoussée lors du sommet
européen de juin 2021 maintenant on
arrive à un point où la démocratie ou la
diplomatie européenne semble se heurter
à une impasse sera en tout cas elle se
heurte à un mur les murs du kremlin ne
permettent pas aux européens de faire
entendre leur point de vue ils n'ont
qu'une arme ses larmes économie gay
c'est la seule qui sont en mesure
d'utiliser jusqu'à quel point on ne le
sait pas et on